hey 42 here tequila heated to 800
degrees Celsius can be made into
diamonds
welcome to riff the snow at the South
Pole reflects sound so well that you
could hear people talking a mile away
nachos were invented by a man named
nacho human teeth evolved from fish
scales last shake of the back was
Victorian slang for a youngest child
salamanders can hear with their lungs in
1989 a Russian psychic was run over by a
train and killed whilst attempting to
prove that he could stop one using the
power of his mind astronaut Harrison
Schmitt is allergic to the moon all the
chicken eggs produced in the world each
year would make an omelet the size of
Northern Ireland when neuroscientist
James Fallon studied the brain scans of
murderers using his own scan as a
control he discovered that he was a
psychopath there are more than 1,000
species of banana and we only eat one of
them john f kennedy's brain was removed
during his autopsy and it's still
missing from 500 years from the 13th
century 70% of Englishmen were called
Robert John Thomas Richard or William
2.8 million American dogs are on
antidepressants traffic lights were
introduced 18 years before the car was
invented 80% of people who are struck by
lightning survived thanks for the view
subscribe for more for Caesar